- [Narrator] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Shell, make the future.
(upbeat music)
- [Megan Leftwich] As an engineer,
I'm always watching how things swim
and sort of thinking about them.
The goal is to really
be inspired by nature,
and take the system
that nature has created
and understand the physics,
and then build that
capability into a new vehicle.
(upbeat music)
I'm Megan Leftwich,
associate professor of
mechanical engineering
at the George Washington University,
and I study sea lions.
Most animals swim with
their tails or their fluke
or whatever's the back of their body.
But sea lions use their fore-flippers
and clap them into their
body to generate a thrust
that can propel them through
the water at incredible speeds.
This form of swimming is found
in almost no other swimming animal.
If we could understand how sea lions move,
we could design vehicles
that could one day
stealthy explore
shipwrecks, underwater mines
or unexplored caves.
In 2013, I started to get
serious about studying sea lions,
and I put together a team of
students and other researchers
and keepers at the
Smithsonian National Zoo.
So I thought, well, we could
use our modern techniques
and really get into the
nitty-gritty of the physics
of how these animals swim.
And so, we 3D-print
three pieces with joints
that represent the elbow
joint and the wrist joint.
And we use different silicone gels
to create a soft, robotic flipper.
And then what we're
able to do is use motors
to actually actuate that.
So, we can recreate
that motion that we got
from filming the animals at the zoo
directly from the animals.
We, then, put this onto
this robotic platform
to study, not only, how the animals move
but how the animals move the water.
And so, understanding the physics of that
can allow us to then build
some of those capabilities
into the engineered vehicles that we have.
It's important to take notes from nature
when inventing technology
because nature has already
done so much of the work us.
And so, by looking around,
we can definitely broaden our horizons
and see solutions that already exist.
We're taking nature, which
seems to solve problems
so elegantly and being inspired
by those elegant solutions.
And you know, we often
say like, nature does that
so much better than us and then move on.
But maybe if we say,
well how do they do it?
We could start to increase
our own functionality.
(upbeat music)